merci David à souligne de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure c'est Nathan socialiste de
Paris vous êtes vice-président de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication on va commencer
par l'actualité et les suites du drame
d'Annecy après l'émotion trois jours
après cette attaque au couteau des
questions qui se sont posées et qui
arrivent dans le débat politique sur la
politique migratoire et sur la réforme
du droit d'asile est-ce que pour vous il
faut réformer ce droit d'asile je pense
qu'on a plusieurs fois réformé et que ce
n'est pas le sujet de cette actualité
croyable
je suis vraiment à chaque fois intérêt
mais là ça dépasse tout quoi je suis
même triste pour la classe politique de
vouloir faire semblant que c'est à la
lumière de ce drame qui nous réunit
entre ce drame et le débat en général
sur l'immigration d'ailleurs vous le
savez que ce débat était alors du jour
avant même cela donc il y a une
instrumentalisation tellement indécente
comment vous dire comment vous dire de
tous ceux qui mettent ça sur la table
j'ai écouté tout à l'heure dans votre
portage le représentant du rassemblement
national qui dit une controvérité toute
simple le droit d'asile à cet homme a
été accordé en Suède et refusait en
France parce qu'il avait déjà en Suède
quatre jours avant le drame donc ce
n'est pas son statut de réfugiés en
France ni des avantages qu'il aurait eu
en France qui lui ont
permis en tous les cas de faire cela la
folie humaine n'a pas de statut ni de
réfugiés ni de résident la folie humaine
n'a pas de nationalité
elle est la folie humaine on est
interpellé et encore plus qu'avant parce
que je n'ai rarement vu disons cette
folie elle est jusqu'à
poignardée des enfants dans un berceau
bon voilà et donc vous parlez assez
aux familles et aux enfants et avoir
beaucoup de dignité à être ensemble et
quand même là on en profite pour
polémiquer je trouve que c'est
désastreux mais hier dans le Journal du
dimanche il y avait un ancien minier
Jean-Pierre Chevènement qui est de
gauche et qui dénonce un droit d'asile
détourné de son but initial et ils sont
même allés dans le sens des républicains
sur la primauté du droit national du
droit national sur le droit européen il
dit également qu'il serait souhaitable
que les demandes d'asile soit faite en
dehors du territoire national qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de ces propos est-ce que
ce sont des pistes à explorer je pense
que c'est encore de l'outrance qu'à
chaque fois on inventera autre chose
sur cette question il a jamais beaucoup
montré le cap à gauche
il a eu beaucoup de vision sur d'autres
sujets mais là-dessus j'ai toujours eu
un désaccord très important avec lui et
malheureusement d'ailleurs ceux qui se
sont formés à cette école là ne sont pas
restés à gauche ont souvent dérivé très
loin à droite et donc je pense que
je ne juge pas Jean-Pierre Chevènement
plus que cela il a apporté beaucoup à la
gauche mais en tous les cas globalement
le discours qui veut à chaque fois aller
plus loin et tellement en plus peu
visionnaire sur ce qui va nous arriver
qui nous arrive déjà un peu c'est quoi
le réchauffement climatique mais ce sont
des dizaines de millions de personnes
qui vont migrer d'abord dans les
continents eux-mêmes de pays à pays et
puis bien entendu vers l'ouest vers
l'Europe vers les États-Unis
et on est qu'au début on a déjà
construit 40 000 kilomètres de Nouvelles
Frontières ces dernières années et de
mur et ça n'a servi à rien et donc si on
se posait maintenant à la question de
comment on accueille pour que justement
ce statut c'est migration faite dans la
misère et le chaos et dans le rejet
ne soit pas un facteur de
déstabilisation si on abordait la
question avec humanité peut-être qu'on
aurait des réponses
qui va se passer cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée nationale et cette notion de
censure la 17e déposée cette notion de
censure déposée par la nuque qui sera
d'ailleurs défendue par la socialisme
Valérie rabot est-ce que on est plutôt
dans le baroud d'honneur cet après-midi
de la part de la nuque
je n'ai pas envie d'employer ce mot
parce que forcément il est péjoratif
c'est un combat qui va continuer sous
d'autres formes
je pense qu'il est jamais perdu parce
qu'il y aura un moment donné le peuple
de toute façon sera convoqué aux urnes
et que la gauche s'est engagée à revenir
sur cette mesure donc c'est un combat
qui continue et si une élection donne la
gauche victorieuse et bien elle
reviendra sur cette mesure vous le ferez
parce que vous étiez déjà engagé à
revenir sur la réforme des retraites des
rives vertes et en 2012 quand François
Hollande est arrivé au pouvoir et vous
l'avez pas fait
de ne pas faire ce que l'on a dit il
faut toujours faire ce que l'on a dit si
on veut garder une crédibilité
voilà je pense que dans bien des
domaines on a payé le fait d'être au
milieu du gué maintenant il faut
incarner beaucoup plus les
transformations assez radicales qu'il
faudra opérer sur le plan social et sur
le de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique pour pour recréer de l'espoir
à gauche on va parler de l'actualité du
Sénat puisque cet après-midi le Sénat
examine la proposition de loi
audiovisuelle alors parmi les
propositions et même la principale
proposition c'est la création d'une
holding qui regroupe les entités de
l'audiovisuel public Radio France
français télévision France media monde
et Lina est-ce que vous y êtes favorable
donc non d'abord
cette loi qui arrive maintenant dans ces
conditions complètement anachroniques
c'est pas le sujet de ni des personnels
de français les visions ni des
directions qui n'en veulent pas ni des
Français qui pensent bien à autre chose
et nous présenter en plus que s'il
s'agit de défendre le service public
alors que beaucoup de mesures viennent
les corner et viennent faire des petits
cadeaux privés au passage comme des
petits cavaliers et puis nous présenter
la holding comme le rempart face à la
concurrence des gafables
j'imagine dans les bords de Google
d'Apple d'Amazon la panique
la holding arrive en France aux abris
bon non franchement c'est pas sérieux
d'autant que c'est la création d'une
structure supplémentaire
qui va
coûterait
de millions en plus ça va être des super
chefs qui vont surveiller les chefs qui
étaient déjà là qui eux-mêmes surveillé
déjà des sous-chefs pas surveiller
diriger on va dire pour être plus
positif c'est pas sérieux et je pense
que
aujourd'hui il faudrait porter
l'attention sur ce que l'on a fait avec
la commission d'enquête sur la
concentration dans les médias le
phénomène des concentrations dans le
privé le phénomène de de des
concentrations verticales de ce qui
possède toute la création toute la la
chaîne
la valeur sur toute la chaîne de la
création
c'est c'est le danger et le danger c'est
dans ce cadre-là Vincent Bolloré qui
veut en plus imposer une idéologie à ces
chaînes en faire une chaîne d'opinion
avec une chaîne d'information alors que
c'est interdit et tout cela c'est
l'actualité le danger pour la démocratie
et on vient porter le fer ou en tous les
cas jeter l'eau propre sur le service
public je pense que ce n'est pas bien
mais pour vous c'est ça c'est pas une
manière de renforcer ce service public
de permettre qui pèse plus
j'ai lu la loi il y a rien qui le
renforce
la première chose c'est le financement
et le financement a été mis en danger
par le gouvernement il faut un
financement pérenne
ça vous inquiète ah ça m'inquiète et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment et au prochain
débat budgétaire mais dans une telle loi
il faudrait que ce soit le cœur à la
deuxième chose c'est de de comment dire
de ne pas faire encore ces cadeaux aux
privés sous leur pression
vous avez bien vu quand même tant qu'à
cette loi qui est apparue il y a une
déclaration de l'ensemble des grands
groupes privés pour dire le service
public a trop d'avantages et il nous en
faut un peu plus et donc dans cette loi
on répond
le doigt sur la couture en disant que on
va supprimer les possibilités ou en tous
les cas encadrés restreints les
possibilités de parrainage entre 20h et
6h du matin ce qui restait de
possibilités au service public pour
avoir plus de moyens donc on pense que
peut-être ils ont non trop quoi alors
que bon et puis et puis
la troisième coupure sur les fictions
dans le privé
c'est à dire on va faire on s'approche
des États-Unis des coupures qui tuent
l'oeuvre
à force de répétition c'est parce que le
de le demander donc vous voyez c'est pas
je ne vois pas ce qu'il y a de
renforcement par contre
vous voyez mieux c'est inutile voilà et
au pire c'est dangereux je répète ça
coûtera au bas mot 40 millions de plus
alors qu'on nous parlait de synergie
pour rationaliser c'est pas ça peut être
oui bien sûr
les sénatoriales approche ce sera le 24
septembre les sénateurs élus par des
grands électeurs on va parler notamment
avec vous David à Soline dessinatori à
Paris puisque vendredi était désigné ses
grands électeurs alors peut-on faire une
projection du résultat et du nombre de
sénateurs par partie alexandre Poussin
c'est l'Everest exercices sinon aux gens
[Musique]
bonjour Ariane bonjour david et Céline
avant de voir le résultat
de sur les projections d'abord on va
voir
ça fonctionne ces élections sénatoriales
à Paris oui d'abord on va expliquer les
choses et bien à Paris 12 sièges de
sénateurs seront renouvelés aux
prochaines élections sénatoriales le
dimanche 24 septembre on le rappelle les
sénateurs sont élus par des grands
électeurs c'est le suffrage universel
indirect et à Paris environ 2800 grands
électeurs vont élire les sénateurs alors
on va d'abord voir qui composent ce
collège de grands électeurs parisiens il
y a les élus locaux les 163 conseillers
de Paris les conseillers régionaux
parisiens également les parlementaires
de la capitale vont voter pour élire les
sénateurs mais la majorité de ce collège
de grands électeurs est composé de
délégués municipaux supplémentaires ils
seront 2644 au total et c'est délégués
et bien ils ont été élus vendredi
dernier par les conseillers de Paris ils
ont été élus à la proportionnelle parmi
plusieurs longues listes de candidats et
en fait ces listes et bien elle reflète
les groupes politiques du Conseil de
Paris notamment la majorité de gauche
autour d'Anne Hidalgo entre les
socialistes les écologistes et les
communistes alors on va regarder et bien
les résultats de vendredi et ces
élections de grands électeurs la liste
du groupe socialiste a obtenu 800 666
délégués au total pour les deux listes
de droite et bien il y aura 898 grands
électeurs supplémentaires 441 pour les
écologistes 212 pour les communistes et
la majorité présidentielle a au total
179 délégués supplémentaires si on
additionne et bien les délégués à la
fois de Renaissance et du MoDem liste de
grands électeurs nous permettent de nous
projeter sur le résultat de ces
sénatoriales à Paris mais oui car au
final et bien tous ces grands électeurs
Parisiens ont une étiquette politique
qui correspond aux différents groupes
politiques du Conseil de Paris leur vote
et donc plutôt prévisibles et on vous a
effectivement préparé une projection des
résultats de ces sénatoriales à Paris
alors une projection qui n'est pas
totalement exacte ça dépendra des
différentes listes de
la candidat puis puisque on le rappelle
ce sera une élection à la
proportionnelle à Paris pour les
sénatoriales les socialistes devraient
obtenir 3 ou 4 sièges ils en ont quatre
actuellement les écologistes vont sans
doute gagner un siège et en avoir deux
alors qu'ils en ont un seul aujourd'hui
du côté et bien des communistes
pourraient conserver un siège de
sénateur mais ce n'est pas acquis ils en
ont deux actuellement et puis du côté de
la droite il devrait conserver quatre
sièges voire en gagner un cinquième cela
dépendra du résultat de la majorité
présidentielle qui pourrait perdre son
siège actuel de sénateur ce sera aussi
un des enjeux de ces sénatoriales à
Paris David Assouline il y aura une
liste d'union au sénatorial à Paris
entre les socialistes et les communistes
c'est la bonne stratégie
ah oui même plus encore plus grandes il
faut les discussions sont en cours avec
les écologistes vous êtes optimiste
Yannick Jadot qui était sur ce plateau
la semaine dernière nous disait qu'il
était évidemment pas fermé à une liste
d'union mais c'est peut-être pas fait
c'était pas fait même à ce moment là
c'était plus que pas fait aujourd'hui
des discussions rebondis elles sont
voies de conclusion donc je peux pas
vous donner le résultat mais il y a
notre volonté claire de le faire depuis
le début de la plus large union
non mais pour l'instant on a déjà passé
un accord donc il y a déjà une liste
entre Paris en commun partie socialiste
communiste et génération parce que il y
a aussi des gros électeurs de génération
donc l'union de la gauche assez
importantes mais pas totale et les
discussions sont correctes mais
aujourd'hui déjà l'alliance que nous
avons créée sans les écologistes c'est
42% des voix des grands électeurs et là
vous êtes pessimiste parce que
la liste la liste PS et parions communs
c'est ça que vous voulez dire elle fait
quatre sièges sont sans doute il y a pas
du tout
donc il y aura un siège communiste un
siège écologiste c'est 7 minimum mais si
la liste est unie
de deux sièges écologistes donc pour
vous il y a quatre sièges socialistes
deux écologistes un communistes
avec les résultats de ce vote des grands
électeurs il y aura cette sièges
certains ensuite selon les divisions des
uns et des autres et ils sont divisés ce
que ne monte pas ce schéma les plus
fortes moyennes vont redistribuer un
siège et
c'est forcément la liste qui aura le
plus de d'unités qui aura le plus de
suffrages donc qui a des fortes chances
de gagner un siège supplémentaire donc
nous sommes ambitieux
vous pouvez faire 8 sièges
c'est notre intention de faire que la
gauche est huissière mais à cette siège
elle a déjà largement gagné et ce que
l'on veut c'est que cette majorité de
gauche municipale
parce que c'est bien ce reflet là de la
de des élections municipales qui
existent au sénatorial et bien
se manifeste aille ensemble gagnent
nettement on gagnera il faut le faire le
plus possible je remarque qu'à chaque
fois on nous promet que la droite sera
unie parce qu'elle a appris du passé
mais elle apprend rarement vraiment
jusqu'au bout et que deux sièges je de
liste de LR c'est à mon avis le minimum
effectivement on rappelle à la droite
est par diviser puisqu'il y aura une
liste de la député européenne agnèse en
face de la liste du parti des
républicains une question sur la gauche
David Assouline dans cette liste d'union
de la gauche aussi notoriale à Paris qui
se prépare et ce qu'il faut des
candidats qui sont favorables à la nups
et notamment partisan de la ligne
d'Olivier Faure le patron du PS
je sais pas ce que vous me posez comme
question ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut
de les meilleures candidats socialistes
il y a des sortants
ont voté et ont déjà placé je peux vous
le dire pour ce qui est des socialistes
un ordre et puis avec les partenaires et
bien il faut intégrer les partenaires et
aujourd'hui
on sait que les deux sortants Rémy Ferro
conduira cette liste on sait que
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie sera
reconduite que
oui on sait que nos partenaires de Paris
en commun avec bernachaumier seront dans
les éligibles on sait aussi que le Parti
communiste avec Yann Brossat sera en
position d'être élu sur cette liste
commune et on sait que dans parce qu'il
faut du renouvellement quand même pour
les socialistes que Colomb Brossel est
une candidate
elle est le produit d'une volonté et de
renouvellement et de féminisation et
d'une élue qui a toujours travaillé pour
le bien commun nous sommes la
représentante la chambre représentante
des collectivités territoires et des
élus locaux c'est une élue locale à
Paris qui aujourd'hui en charge de la
Propreté en quelle position elle sera du
coup vous allez voir parce que selon le
fait
non mais je vous dis en position
éligible donc le problème c'est que les
positions seront connues
quand il aura ou pas l'accord avec les
écologistes voilà puisque
c'est pas nous qui proposons la place
qui leur revient donc vous savez on sait
on calcule c'est assez froid il
représente deux
éligibles donc ils auront deux dans
force mais j'ai arrêté de faire des
comptes d'apothicaire
de toute façon il y aura 7 élus donc
quand je dis éligible ils sont dans les
7 premiers et ensuite il y aura une
discussion à avoir sur qui peut être en
charnière en 8 externe et tout ça c'est
de la cuisine qui n'intéresse pas nos
auditeurs je pense et ensuite la
question une dernière question
politiquement alors il y aura et bien un
groupe socialiste au Sénat qui sera
renouvelé et ce que vous pensez
justement que les sénateurs socialistes
qui sont favorables à la nups à cet
accord avec la France insoumise vont
devenir majoritaire dans ce groupe
socialiste au Sénat et que du coup et
bien Patrick Kanner pourrait en perdre
la présidence puisque Patrick kaner lui
est plutôt hostile à cet accord avec
elle moi je ne comprends pas
pour moi ce n'est pas un sujet mais
sincèrement il y a des socialistes il y
a eu un congrès qui ont chacun sa ligne
d'abord il y a pas de anti-up c'est pas
vrai nous sommes moi par exemple
qui est sout
refondation et qui est dans ce
courant qui s'appelle Théo 3 dans les
congrès
on est pour le dépassement de cette
nupes pour une union de la gauche encore
plus large non mais pour l'union de la
gauche mais pas pour la nuque telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui voilà donc nous
sommes pour un dépassement mais nous ne
sommes pas les seuls j'ai entendu marine
tondeuillier des verres le dire un peu
même ces derniers temps Olivier fort il
faut une nouvelle étape la nupesse a été
un tiers des voix même pas
30%, on peut pas le gouverner le pays et
gagner une élection avec 30%. donc ce
qu'il faut la dépasser c'est une
évidence si on veut gagner et
aujourd'hui il faut gagner parce que
sinon c'est Marine Le Pen et sinon c'est
l'extrême droite donc maintenant il faut
arrêter de jouer avec ça et le
rassemblement de la gauche il doit être
global il y a Bernard Cazeneuve il y a
un centre gauche il y a une gauche de à
gauche il y a ceux qui veulent incarner
le centre de la gauche j'aimerais que le
PS incarne le centre de la gauche pour
être encore celui qui rassemble et sur
sa droite et sur sa gauche pour pouvoir
gagner et je pense que c'est ça que vous
avez beaucoup de gens qui aujourd'hui
peut rassembler la gauche
est-ce que vous soutenez l'initiative de
Bernard Cazeneuve ce week-end je vous ai
répondu Bernard Cazeneuve a lancé un
mouvement c'est quelqu'un que je
respecte c'est un même un ami il veut
incarner le centre gauche à refondation
que je représente aussi dans cette
nébuleuse des courants de la gauche on
veut être le centre de la gauche parce
qu'il faut un sang de la gauche et nous
on situe notre traction pour que le
Parti socialiste soit ce centre de la
gauche lui a choisi de le quitter voilà
ça c'est sa position que je respecte
complètement nous voulons rassembler
nouvelle voie du père je ne sais pas
Nono on n'est pas là au stade des
incarnations pour une présidentielle et
si on s'amuse encore à mettre ça avant
tout le reste avant de refonder un
projet crédible un projet de
transformation un projet qui tire le
bilan de la gauche au pouvoir avant qui
a été trop timoré qui n'a pas pris la
mesure des transformations radicales il
faut avoir qui qui a pas pris la mesure
que le socialibéralisme était un poison
et qui nous ferait être impuissant face
aux inégalités qui se creusent mais
aussi qui prennent la mesure que le
social populisme est une impasse qui
nous mène droite au mur aujourd'hui et
et donc il faut construire un projet
aujourd'hui qui incarne mieux cette
sociale écologie cette cette
écosocialisme on le prend dans le sens
qu'on veut mais les deux maintenant sont
les urgences qui soient républicaines et
européenne voilà comment rassemble la
gauche et c'est un travail d'abord et
ensuite on verra les incarnations ceux
qui peuvent incarner un tel projet
aux yeux des Français et qui l'incarne
au sens qui porte avec conviction ce
contenu politique on va remercier Alex
merci Alex à tout à l'heure on va
reparlera avec vous et pour terminer on
va aller voir Jacques Pâquier Jacques
paquet directeur de la rédaction du
journal du Grand Paris bonjour Jacques
merci d'être avec nous avec vous Jacques
va revenir sur la polémique autour de
l'élu parisien pierre Lichia d'abord
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler de
quoi il s'agit
absolument on va parler de d'exhumation
administrative c'est ce à quoi on
procède lorsqu'une tombe dans un
cimetière n'est voit sa concession ne
pas être renouvelée ou qu'une tombe est
à l'abandon et un conseiller régional
d'Île-de-France a posté sur les réseaux
sociaux une vidéo tendance à démontrer
que les fossoyeurs du cimetière de
Pantin et singulièrement dans le carré
juif de ce cimetière s'affranchissent
des règles qui les enjoignent de ne pas
manipuler les ossements à la pelleteuse
des allégations des affirmations que la
mairie de Paris a à démenti adoptant
leur son dernier conseil une
délibération autorisant la mairie à
attaquer c'était lui régional monsieur
Assouline quel regard vous portez sur
cette polémique là
j'ai envie de vous dire que l'imposture
de ce monsieur je la connais depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs il a alimenté
la trappe nigaud l'imposture de sa cage
Paris pas mal que maintenant ce soir
dévoilé des masqués pour le plus grand
nombre mais moi je ne l'ai jamais douté
de de la façon dont il triché avec les
faits de dont il exagéré dont il faisait
un bashing
infernal de tout ce qui pouvait taper
sur Anne Hidalgo que l'ensemble du
Conseil de Paris de des groupes voté
ensemble de démasquer cette imposture
d'aller en justice pour mettre un ola à
cela est important le haut le coeur
c'est que on va jusqu'à utiliser
la mort et tout ce qu'il y a autour pour
encore détruire politiquement les uns ou
les autres
vraiment il y a des mœurs sont
politiques qui doivent vite cesser les
seuls qui en profiteront ce sont les
extrêmes mais notamment l'extrême droite
qui opporte du pouvoir que chacun se
mette ça dans la tête ne le disent pas
seulement pour amuser la galerie parce
que quand ils sont au pouvoir alors on
ne rigole plus
justement
vous êtes historien également qu'elle
regarde vous portez sur l'évolution du
débat public à l'heure des fake news
est-ce que faut-il que les élus y
répondent systématiquement
il y a deux attitudes il faut pas les
relayer on y répondant mais quand elles
ont envahi l'espace public si on y
répond pas c'est ça qui reste comme
vérité alternative comme dirait les
autres donc c'est la grande difficulté
que l'on a et je pense qu'il faut
surtout surtout que les réseaux sociaux
assument le responsabilité de faire un
vrai tri algorithmique et aujourd'hui
dans les algorithmes de ces réseaux
sociaux c'est la fake news c'est
l'outrance et l'insulte c'est la
violence qui est primée qui monte
d'abord et bien quand on aura inversé
l'échelle de valeur dirais-je peut-être
contribuera à ce qu'au moins sur les
réseaux sociaux ça diminue merci
merci d'avoir été avec nous la
passerelle du centre aquatique olympique
inauguré c'était la Une du journal du
Grand Paris cette semaine merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité merci David et
souligne d'avoir été notre invité
pendant cette première demi-heure et
peut-être avant puisque vous allez
quitter le Sénat mais vous reviendrez
nous voir avant de quitter le Sénat ce
sera fin septembre on a un petit peu de
temps et bien si vous m'invitait je
serai là avec plaisir
[Musique]
on reparlera justement de la campagne
des sénatoriales puisque vendredi était
désigné les grands électeurs on est allé
voir comment ça s'est passé du côté
d'Arras dans le Pas-de-Calais reportage
à suivre mais d'abord on va écrire notre
prochaine invité un autre élu de Paris
Sylvain Maillard nous rejoindre
[Musique]